[Music]
this is moonlight the best picture
congratulations heartfelt
congratulations for such a beautiful
film and story being told and being
recognized describe the mix of emotions
that you felt when all that was
happening at the at the end of the
evening at the end of the award show
yeah you know we spent so much time with
the law and crew it was bittersweet you
know I think when you're sitting in the
room you know I've gone through this so
much they call the name they don't call
it a you know it is what it is you get
over it I gotten through and like
everyone else I was applauding you know
I was celebrating the win
and I could see in Jordan's face you
know that he was speaking the truth and
in that moment I just felt I wanted to
feel compassion for him I'm pretty sure
the first thing I do when I get up on
stage is to give him a hug because it
couldn't have been easy but you know
these things happen you know they happen
and then very quickly you know I just
feel so thankful to 8:24 for giving us
the financing for supporting the film so
I'm happy right now you know but but I
can't not have those guys in my heart
the crouppen
you